San Francisco's like the Charlie Sheen
of cities remember Charlie Sheen a few
years back when he went wild and he
needed a makeover sometimes you just
need to take two years off fire your
manager go to rehab maybe get the
paparazzi to take a picture of you with
your children that's what San Francisco
needs they need to get out of the
headlines because every headline you see
flesh-eating virus yeah a toddler
overdoses on fentanyl popolosa gets
hammered in the head they need to chill
because this whole experiment with
social justice has blown up in their
face it has gone too far too fast and
it's starting to kill people and it's
killing the city of San Francisco
when you have a comedian like that that
talented ridicule you yeah ridicule is
powerful Jon Stewart knows that all the
late night people know it it's more
powerful than explaining why explain
when you can ridicule and especially if
it comes from the left San Francisco
doesn't listen to the five they listen
to Dave Chappelle and when Chappelle's
mocking them that actually might make
them wake up although I don't actually
think he had Indian food in the
tenderloin there's no good restaurants
there are you sure I'm positive I had
Johnny look into it do you want to fact
check Dave Chappelle yeah I know I know
that's a lot that's why he doesn't watch
keep it up water